[Music]
I'm so excited to be sitting here with
the Electra and lovely lauren cohan
thank you from walking dead
you play Maggie or Margaret to the
die-hard fan this is our first meeting
hey it was authentic yeah yeah prefer
that you didn't actually yeah there
could you see some something wrong the
whole interview like it could just be
kind of Leaning ratings just went down
yeah now I'm picking up a bit of an
accent and I'm one of those Cammie
people that yeah okay I don't want to do
it I want to know the story so I'm sorry
to be so typical but well you what is
the story where do you hail from I hail
from New Jersey I was born in New Jersey
I was gonna say New Jersey yeah I do
have this now yeah I moved to England
you gonna catch it I hear that you do a
really good English accent aye I'd like
to try yeah I'm one of those hams I do
like I said banana
okay how about alluminium I would
clearly its aluminium yeah yeah ten
years you suddenly start doing it
full-time
well I visited London and every once in
a while I'll try to pass I'll try to
pass as a real bread yeah you look a
little [ __ ] I got some of that yeah I
got something wrong wrong with Prince
William or something no new Prince but I
love cheers Cheers really feels a boy
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
a friend of mine as a Boston accent
sometimes when I fight with my mother
I'm always from Chicago I'm your best
friend
okay from high school though and you've
moved on and I sell Cutco knives okay so
I'm taking your place and that first row
third fight and now my knives are
everywhere the pennies that I cut with
the shears are everywhere and now you
have to tell me that you want me to
clean up my knives okay so um wait hold
hold on we need to leave late yeah can I
actually say something to you that I
don't mind us living together I know we
were high school we are really good
friends but I moved away oh my god
Russia because I had a sex change
you're now a woman yes but I were again
you said that you are dealing in knives
I think I want to see how the man cut
pennies and so I invite you back to live
with me yes nothing else
yes from this interview yes oh yeah oh
god okay you're gonna get cast as some
sort of icy Russian woman
don't worry hope so yeah I'm hope I'm
hope so
[Music]